steps one through four draw divide
calculate combine draw divide calculate
combine it's really simple
let's have a go at this example
here's this kind of upside down looking
l shape
okay i don't i'm sorry
um by the way by the way this is one of
the reasons why if you're drawing you're
diagnosed please pick up a pencil if
there's something else maybe just put a
clean line through it
um and then just to make money without
the problem uh it's it's okay it can be
close enough
as long as it has all the important
pieces okay so
please with me just like i have i've
already done the first step
um with this upside down turned around l
shape okay
but i'd love you to draw it with me okay
it's not a complicated
shape um you should use your ruler so
that it does
look reasonably accurate and it's not
like
wavy edges or anything like that
the first thing we're going to do is
draw it now
drawing is not just useful so that you
can see something and understand it
but we can't do any of these other steps
without a drawing
you can try and do it in your hand but
you're kind of setting yourself up to
really have difficulty
okay so this is a composite shape
it's not a rectangle it's not a square
it's not a parallelogram
but we can think of it as
made up of other kinds of shapes if we
combine it in the right way
so for instance
i'll turn it back on a bit later okay
yep a lot of people aren't aware
including me let's think about
let's think about how we can divide up
this shape
okay there's lots of different ways
here's one having finished
drawing this shape okay if you've got
another color
that would be handy but it's not
compulsory i'm going to divide this up
right down here and i'm going to put
this in another color
in dotted lines okay so now if i divide
up this is my second step right
if i've divided up this shape now lo and
behold
i have one two rectangles
can you see that and i can work out each
of the rectangles on their own
that's sweet right i've got formulas for
those okay but before i can do that
i've drawn it i've divided it because i
put in this new line i need to label
something that's missing okay
um firstly i've got two rectangles i
don't want to confuse them with each
other
so i'm going to call this one rectangle
one
and i'll call this other one over here
rectangle
two that's just so i can distinguish
between them okay
rectangle one as we're about to do i can
work out its area
no problem right i have its breadth
over here i have its length so far so
good
but when i look at rectangle two i'm
missing something
right i have a length but i don't have a
breath
right what can i do to work this out
yeah daniel you
get like the top one so twenty yes
yeah very good it's going to be the
difference between those two
it's 12 right very good and lots of you
spotted that fantastic
so that's a really important kind of
distance to have on there and you
use the information given to you on the
diagram
to work out the bits that you need to
label okay
so what i've done here is i've labeled
not just
the different areas i've labeled
the different areas that i got and i
also labeled any missing lengths
length that i need to do
the next step okay so we've done step
one we drew it we've done step two we've
divided it up
now into step three we want to calculate
there are two pieces and we'll just
calculate them one at a time
so we've got the area of the first
rectangle
and it's just length times breadth
that's
15 times eight 15
times eight okay now we could reach for
our calculators here but i think we can
do without them
eight times ten is just eighty and then
eight times 5
is half of that it's 40. so it's just
going to be a
120. by the way
this is an area we've looked at units
before what area
unit is it yeah centimeters
squared very good right so in some ways
you can kind of see it because this 15
is actually 15 centimeters
right so there's centimeters there and
this eight is actually
eight centimeters so look there's
centimeters times centimeters hence
centimeters squared that's the first
rectangle let's just do
the second one okay so we've already got
the dimensions up here it's going to be
7 by 12 seven seven by twelve
centimeters who's good with the
seven times ten what's 84 very good on
the ball the point well done
84 centimeters squared
so now we're done with those
calculations we drew it we divided it up
we calculated all the
parts we divided now is the last step
combining so i tend to write down here
total area that's how i know because
i've got all these equations flying
around
now i know which ones which the total
area
is this plus this so let's write it down
and then you can give me an answer
120 plus 84.
okay do you want it 200 fantastic well
done 204
centimeters squared cool stop okay
so well done we went through the four
steps and they kind of just
went like that really we drew it we
divided we calculated and then we
combined now just one little quick note
before we end okay
you'll notice i say combined and i
didn't just say add them up
um we did add them up this time but
sometimes
combining means subtracting
so you don't have to draw this with me
but
actually i'll ask you to put your pens
down just so you can see this really
quickly
i'm going to replay this super fast just
put your pens down because i don't want
you to worry about
writing this out i just want you to see
that it's another way of doing this
i've got all my same dimensions here
right
and we divided it up by putting a line
down here okay can you see i could have
divided it another way
couldn't i yeah what's another way yeah
ethan there's two more have done it
gone across yep and then oh you could
have gone across and up and made it
three squares yeah very good
oh three ways three rectangles yep good
okay so uh let me say that first thing
right i could have gone across here
and it would have still made two
rectangles but there'd be other
rectangles wouldn't they
okay not only that i could do i could do
both
i could divide it like that i wouldn't
do that though can anyone give me a
suggestion as
why i probably won't yeah it will
because there will be structures
20 times 15 so pretend it's an entire
square oh wait you're getting onto
you're gonna yeah okay i'm gonna get to
yours in a second real that's actually
why i draw this new one
nathan jonas just why would i maybe not
do both of these divisions
yeah it's just like i'm just kind of
needlessly making work for myself it's
like i could do it in two rectangles
why do it in three right okay now let me
get on to what will was mentioning
is what we will say right can you see
i can think of this as two rectangles
added together
but i can also think of it
yeah as two rectangles one
taken away from another right so you
don't need to wrap this down but you can
see
i've got a big rectangle here right so
if i call that
like i'll literally call it big
rectangle okay
what's the area of the big rectangle
it's 20 by 15
which is yeah cuteness yeah
300 very good and then i've got a
smaller one here
right i need both of these lengths
what's this length
that's going to be eight and we already
worked out the other one is 12
right so i can say the small rectangle
is 96 very good and so when i do the
total
i'm not going to add those like one is
being taken away from
the other does that make sense so i
would go not add but
subtract which of course is going to
give us the same answer as before
because it's the same shape
okay so what i would advise you to do is
don't just like draw the first line that
you see
okay look at it carefully as you draw it
out it will help you see
where is the most efficient way the most
quickest path through to work out the
area nice and easily